deux heures de sérieuses discussions
pour s'accorder à croire le patron des
républicains sur la marche à suivre il
n'est pas question ni d'impact avec le
gouvernement dit d'une coalition de
quelque nature que ce soit nous sommes
en opposition à la fois à en marche au
rassemblement national et à l'extrême
gauche et nous restons sur cette ligne
aucun pacte avec le gouvernement
musique avertissements aux quelques voix
qui se taisent maintenant et qui
appelait hier à coopérer avec la
république en marche à celle là les
poids lourds du parti répondent non non
non et si des voix isolées ce que vous
en avez entendu dès hier soir d'ailleurs
pas pas nombreuses si des voix isolées
se risquer à dire que nous serions dans
une logique de pacte de gouvernement
comme j'ai entendu ce sont des voix qui
montent en tout cas elle ne parle que
pour elle même pas loin d'avoir échappé
au pire dans les urnes perdant sa place
de première force d'opposition dans
l'hémicycle les républicains entendent
pourtant bien redonner son poids
politique à la droite
satisfait de retrouver l'assemblée
nationale et d'avoir
montré la résistance très forte des
républicains sur une ligne claire
d'opposition au maquereau nisme on n'est
pas là pour bloquer non n'est pas à
vendre
donc pas question de rentrer dans une
majorité présidentielle pas question
d'un accord de gouvernement
s'agissant de l'action parlementaire du
parti pas question de suivre les
extrêmes quant aux propositions des
marcheurs nous ne sommes pas des
va-t-en-guerre donc on va pas mettre le
feu à la maison on respecte les
institutions on votera cas par cas sur
les textes de lois etc on ne votera
évidemment pas de motion de censure et
les filles au moment de la déclaration
du gouvernement mais je ne vois pas
pourquoi on en fait plus rêver d'un
nombre suffisant de députés à
l'assemblée pour imposer sa loi le parti
de droite comptent bien tirer son
épingle du jeu au sénat où le groupe ait
l'air est majoritaire le paradoxe est
l'air à la chapitre que l'on tout de
suite avec mes invités béatrice giblin
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes géographe
directrice de la revue hérodote jean
garrigues bonsoir bienvenue historien
président du comité l'histoire
parlementaire et auteur de la tentation
du sauveur histoire d'une passion
française aux éditions payot je sais pas
où le sauveur au lendemain d'un scrutin
pareil je pense que tout le monde le
cher jean daniel lévy bonsoir bienvenue
pousser vers le directeur délégué de
harris interactive matthieu croissandeau
évidemment il rester à mes côtés
batterie jib là je commence par ce jeudi
le paradoxe parce que les élèves ils
sont à la fois affaiblie et renforcée
par les résultats d'hier renforcer il
faut voir affaibli c'est sûr ils ont
quand même perdu la moitié de leur
circonscription donc c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui est d'ailleurs étonnant parce que à
la limite ils apparaissent avec une
certaine superbe parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont en situation de pouvoir
négocier
ses
310 voix ou 60 voix qu'ils y lisons
alors qu'ils sont quand même pris une
claque qui est aussi très importante et
puis ils ont le sentiment qu'ils vont
pouvoir se venger d'une certaine façon
vis à vis de macron qui les a quand même
fortement affaiblie depuis 2010 est
hélas ils vont donner la note si vous
voulez d'une certaine façon ils vont
faire payer pour surtout que par rapport
effectivement au score de pécresse qui
était à moins de 5% il pouvait avoir le
sentiment que tout était parti sauf que
l'ancrage local à payer la incontestable
incontestablement il a payé dans des
zones qui sont de mon point de vue assez
intéressant par exemple il ya plus de l
air à paris terminé en appuyant en
revanche si vous regardez la haute saône
si vous regardez la haute marne si vous
regardez la marne je choisi justement
cette zone qui est une zone assez en
déshérence avec de très faibles densités
avec du vieillissement de population
c'est à dire le sentiment que
forme de désespérance bon et que les
lieux l'air qui est là qui est là
généralement il lui depuis déjà quelque
temps au fond il est presque plus
rassurant qu'un candidat et rennes qu'on
connaît pas bien et cet ancrage là ce
travail avec quelques scènes qui sont
d'ailleurs assez bon d'ailleurs je pense
au maire de vesoul
cc présent donc là ils ont bien ils ont
bien tenu si vous voulez en revanche l
air sur la côte d'azur mise à part
ciotti et quelques autres là ils ont été
balayés mais moi je pense d'une certaine
façon que reconquête a vraiment servi de
marchepied pour conforter et raide c'est
à dire que vous aviez tout une
l'électorat qui avait du mal à voter rn
d'abord parce que l air très longtemps a
dit pas question front républicain
votent pas et rennes le passage par
reconquête avec un zemmour qui a touché
un électorat on va dire moins populaire
un peu plus chic un peu plus bourgeois
je mets des guillemets évidemment ça ça
ça a permis à cet électorat-là de
basculer sur les rênes au deuxième tour
ça les a désinhibé certaines
situations c'était plus honteux soit on
prend et du coup on a quand même cette
bande tout à dans le var dans les alpes
maritimes dans l'est dans les
bouches-du-rhône enfin c'est tout à fait
quand même impressionnant ce ce sud est
là alors que sur le nord cet autre chose
jean daniel lévy vous n'allez pas
répéter ce que béatrice giblin le dire
mais quand vous analysez le vote ait l
air qu elle qu'elle fait saillant aux
ressorts pour nom je pars et péter schep
sur la haute saône et sur la haute-marne
moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
entièrement basculé du côté du
rassemblement national en fait moi je me
suis pas trompé j'avais l'impression que
c'était en tout cas elle est donc
effectivement il ya des résistances
locales qui sont absolument certaine ce
concert est une façon face et que l'axé
gauche droite n'est pas complètement
éliminé en fait de lui le schéma
politique et que quand on interroge
aujourd'hui les électeurs et quand on
leur demande justement de se positionner
sur un axe gauche droite à peu de choses
près rien à 20% qu'il ne réponde pas mon
à 80 % qui me disent soit qui se
positionne à gauche qui soutiennent à
droite et voire même avec une proximité
partidaire là après la difficulté c'est
qu'elle est débouché politique qui peut
avoir avec leur
appréhension de ce que peuvent être les
grands trajets société et la manière
dont ça peut se traduire politiquement
quoi qu'il en soit les alertes ont
vraiment effectuer ce travail d'ancrage
local notamment dans des pas forcément
dans les grands centres urbains mais
dans des endroits justement où emmanuel
macron n'est pas entièrement parvenu à
pouvoir se construire et donc ce sont
des lieux effectivement pour partie mais
qui viennent d'être d'être indiquer si
on regarde quelques bastions à la moitié
des villes de plus de 9000 habitants
sont à l'air sept régions sur dix est
évidemment on est sur public sénat y
avait encore une majorité forte au sénat
c'est pour ça que je disais il ya il ya
un paradoxe à dire qu'il sorte affaibli
du scrutin on est d'accord 40 % de
sièges en moins mais y'a c'est encore
une forte politique il s'était une force
politique d'ailleurs qui a bien résisté
au rassemblement national quand on
regarde si je me trompe pas je crois qu
25 duels de deuxième tour entre le fn et
le rassemblement national entre eux ndlr
et les élèves ont gagné 23 de ses 25
confrontations directement avec le
rassemblement national jean garé il y a
à une personnalité politique dont on n'a
pas parlé dans notre premier débat alors
qu'on a évoqué le la thématique et leers
et edouard philippe et je pense que
c'est quand même important de citer son
potentiel pouvoir d'attraction pour une
partie des députés a l'air quel est-il
comment vous l'évaluez ce potentiel
pouvoir d'attraction est ce qu'il existe
encore dans un parti l air qui semble en
tout cas à l'instant t plutôt pencher
vers une ligne on va dire ciotti
wauquiez oui ça je pense qu'il faut
entendre encore rester très brute très
frais dans la salle très prudent
j'observe il me semble avoir entendu que
très récemment gérard larcher le
président du sénat a rencontré le
président de la république gérard
larcher s'est quand même l'homme des
négociations c'est comme l'homme qui met
de l'huile dans les rouages de
rapprochement éventuel entre la majorité
ensemble et et les républicains donc je
pense qu'il faut encore rester prudent
là dessus mais là où vous avez raison
c'est qu'il y aura de toute manière au
moins deux lignes au sein de ce groupe
lr et qu'il ya une ligne qui en aucune
façon ne souhaiterait évidemment être
phagocyté par par edouard philippe et
effectivement pour vous rejoindre il ya
beaucoup de cas comme ça où on voit et
c'est moi c'est à dire ce que j'avais
prédit comme beaucoup qui auraient une
résistance de parce que parce que les
élections municipales nous l'avait
enseigné il y avait une résistance très
forte à la fois du parti socialiste et
des républicains dans l'est dans les
petites communes une résistance
évidemment au sénat etc alors edouard
philippe par rapport à ça il est il
avait il pouvait avoir une position
charnière s'il y avait une majorité
absolue de weeds d'ensemble qui tenait
au groupe horizon ce qui était une
éventualité au départ son chien majorité
absolue à ce moment là cet horizon était
et est pivot le fait d'avoir
éventuellement de pouvoir contracter
éventuellement sur des majorités d'idées
ou à géométrie variable des alliances
avec l air le met dans une position où
il n'est plus le n'est plus charnière et
ça c'est un affaiblissement pour lui
c'est un riche chez les riches mais déjà
pauvres chez les pauvres et vous l'avez
vu hier soir d'un fip vous avez vu
françois bayrou hier soir manon et aux
curieux et que les poids lourds ceux qui
sont censés être et pas de cette
nouvelle façon de faire la politique les
îles cette défaite n'est pas la leur ils
n'ont pas de leçons à en tirer et ils
n'ont absolument pas à l'assumer on voit
bien que pour l'instant il la laisse à
emmanuel macron et e envisagerons
peut-être de reconstruire mais ça va
poser quand même un petit souci parce
que pour faire venir les gens à vous
faut vous et métiers quelque chose un
signe alors ils ont fait campagne c'est
vrai edouard philippe a multiplié les
déplacements françois bayrou on a fait
on les soupçonnait parfois dans leur
propre majorité de faire davantage les
déplacements pour eux mêmes que pour que
pour la majorité mais il faut qu'ils
aient un propos politique fort qui soit
autre chose qu'il faut réformer la
france et faire les réformes dont la
france a besoin qu'il ya peu la
ritournelle que chantait doit fil depuis
un an là il faut une proposition
politique en tout cas un constat un
débouché une offre politique forte 6,6
il aspire aux plus hautes fonctions 2027
il ya un moment il va devoir poser un
marqueur alors là il est emmanuel macron
ce de gérer sa défaite mais ce moment
vous devra venir et peut-être sans doute
un peu plus tôt kenny qui ne l'aurait
imaginé pour les raisons vient d'écrire
gens dire que c'est vrai que dans dans
un groupe a mûri et ben il a une
influence se rabougrit alors on va on va
des zooms et un peu on va élargir un peu
le propos en revenant un chiffre qu'on
s'empresse tous d'oublier à chaque
soirée électorale à 20h02 c'est celui de
l'abstention
53,79 % c'est plus un point par rapport
au premier tour et
c'est moins que le second tour de 2017
qui était à 57,36 béatrice giblin faut
surtout pas l'oublier soutien à banon il
est extrêmement important non parce que
en plus c'est une moyenne ce que vous
venez de dire ça veut dire qu'il ya des
endroits où on est à 70% d'abstention en
particulier quand vous regardez certains
coins de la seine-saint-denis quand vous
regardez les dom là c'est en arrive à
des taux d'abstention qui sont vraiment
extrêmement près préoccupons
là alors on dit toujours bombe à
l'assemblée ne représente plus rien ils
savent pas ce qui se passe à l'assemblée
c'est quand même essentiellement les
jeunes mais c'est vrai que c'est très
nombreux mais c'est pas quand même non
plus que des jeunes alors il ya que les
retraités ou là ça va ça va voter sans
doute que on a appris
depuis très longtemps l'importance du
vote je pensais à une dame en face de
chez moi 107 ans il était allé voter
donc je me dis vraiment ça tient
beaucoup mais cette cette question de
l'abstention qui était quand même aussi
élevé aux
présidentielles même si elle était on se
rassure c'est plus de 60% bruit d'accord
mais enfin on a connu des 80% de
participation aux présidentielles donc
on est vraiment dans une sorte d
affiliation on va dire il y a plus
vraiment de partie les potez que je fais
c'est que il ya plus d'encadrement si
vous voulez je pense que très dans les
années 50 ou 60 si on avait demandé un
certain nombre d'ouvriers de la
métallurgie de la haute marne s'ils
savaient exactement ce qui se passait à
l'assemblée nationale est ce qu'on y
faisait je suis pas sûr qu'on aurait une
réponse très claire mais on était
encadré par le travail par le syndicat
par l'église parfois par l'huma 7
et tous les journaux épigones ya surtout
tirèrent des centaines de milliers
les gens qui tous les dimanches était
sur les marchés étaient présents bref il
y avait un encadrement là aujourd'hui il
ya plus d'encadrement c'est pas sur les
réseaux sociaux vous êtes encadré soit
vous êtes dans une bulle soit vous
flottez
largement alors ça le constat on le
partage mais enfin les sections faut
bien les invente et voilà mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire ça sur je ne crois
absolument pas aux solutions du genre
participation débat regarder les budgets
participatifs qui a dans l'est dans les
mairies quelle participation dérisoire
absolument dérisoires pourtant c'est
souvent leur quartier c'est leur impôt
pages et il ya toute raison pour se
mobiliser et ça se mobilise pas un grand
un grand débat oui c'est vrai il ya eu
donc pas mal de monde pour aller écrire
des cahiers de doléances participer puis
après bon comme on en a pas fait grand
chose les historiens feront quelque
chose de cahiers de doléances mais pour
l'instant on n'en a pas fait donc c'est
extrêmement difficile
là je pense qu'elle parle de vote
obligatoire serait une solution jean
gary est ce que finalement le le
résultat d'hier ne retarde pas
la réforme institutionnelle que kiki et
est qui qui semblait dans les tuyaux on
pourrait on pourrait le penser parce
qu'on se dit que à travers ce qui s'est
passé dans ces élections législatives
finalement le la représentation
parlementaire a épousé à peu près le
paysage politique français c'est à dire
cette tripartition avec le la start-up
nationaux au centre où les modérés je
préfère ce terme là et d'autres d'autres
côtés de forces protestataires radical
est entré entre eux d'ailleurs la
survivance de ce qu'était le bipartisme
qu'on a connu jusqu'à présent donc on
pourrait se dire que 7,7 comme on dirait
ce retour d'une d'une photographie
démocratique ou adéquate à la démocratie
pourrait être un élément de
réhabilitation au moins de ce
contre-pouvoir que doit être le
parlement et c'est vrai il faut pas se
le nier la spécificité dans ces
élections législatives c'est que la
majorité des français et notamment les
jeunes voient le parlement comme une
chambre d'enregistrement de la volonté
présidentielle c'est d'ailleurs comme ça
au fond des fonds que le général de
gaulle l'avait souhaité il faut pas se
faire de l'illusion mais en tout cas il
ya cette image là mais cette image là et
la réhabilitation du enfin un semblant
de réhabilitation du parlement ne
résoudra pas le problème de la fatigue
démocratique de la manière dont les
français ne se reconnaissent plus dans
les canaux dans les circuits dans les
rituels de la démocratie c'est quelque
chose qui a calé en train de disparaître
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire pour
mathieu je changeais il faut rappeler
que c'est un mal profond mais c'est pas
un mal français non seulement mal qui
touche la balle est donc démocratie
comme si on était un peu des enfants
gâtés de la démocratie est entièrement
on vote depuis maintenant soixante dix
ans dans des conditions libre et
heureuse enfin plus pour certains mais
moi c'est
un mal qui touche tout le monde un coup
d'oeil dans le rétroviseur si on regarde
un peu l'histoire de notre vème
république on trouve qu'un précédent
c'était 1988 regarder il y avait 2 175
députés en 88 pour la majorité
présidentielle celle de françois
mitterrand évidemment et puis ensuite on
a on a des majorités à 470 412 193 est
ici à 245 jean garrigues je reviens vers
vous une nouvelle fois c'est à
l'historien évidemment que je m'adresse
françois mitterrand en 81 8 était
président michel rocard était premier
ministre mais il ne manquait que le 10
mai mais que 14 ça change quand même
l'admet ça change énormément de 14 et 44
c'est pas la même histoire sans créer
des majorités et puis ensuite on en a
parlé dans le premier débat il y avait 1
49 3 qui étaient beaucoup plus faciles à
utiliser à l'époque 28 x 28 utilisation
sur treize textes on a beaucoup vernet
et que enfin michel rocard elle record
de man absolue et en plus ils
disposaient d'un conseiller juriste guy
carcassonne qui est un type exceptionnel
et qui est un expert pour trou pour
aller trouver des majorités d'idées des
majorités à géométrie variable beaucoup
en s'appuyant souvent d'ailleurs sur le
parti communiste mais aussi sur le sur
le centre droit le centre gauche aussi
donc donc l'équation n'était pas du tout
la même qu'aujourd'hui parce que ce qui
pouvait se rallier ils avaient aussi une
culture et de gouvernement partager avec
ceux qui est qu'ils étaient les
communistes avaient été au gouvernement
déjà à partir de 1980 donc il y avait
des des liens très forts qui pouvaient
exister aujourd'hui c'est plus compliqué
le fils de michel rocard qui est un
homme de combien sur un petit
politiquement été pour la discussion
l'élaboration de compromis qu'il ne
conseillerait pas qu'on me les
compromissions donc si on était quand
même 17 c'est différent et ça nous amène
à parler
d'elisabeth bornes évidemment puisqu'on
va travailler là la comparaison il avait
deux bandes qui a déjeuné avec mm macro
aujourd'hui première ministre fragilisé
en poste depuis moins de deux mois mais
l'opposition réclame déjà sa démission
par exemple jordan bardella le président
par intérim du rassemblement national je
ne vois pas dans ces conditions quand
madame borne peut rester à la tête à la
tête du gouvernement et comment est ce
qu'on peut continuer que la politique
sur laquelle était pourtant battu et qui
a été rejetée hier par les français qui
était la feuille de route des manuels
mâcon voilà on parle d'elisabeth bornes
maintenant dans ce débat avec steve
jourdain pour commencer re bonsoir steve
on le disait fragilisé il avait deux
bornes après 7 ce scrutin est peut-être
elle était nue mais peut-être par son
propre score dans le calvados oui la
première mini se présentait dans la
commune de vire 6e circonscription du
calvados au deuxième tour elle était
opposé à un candidat de la nuque noël
gauchard le résultat on va le voir ça
passe ça passe mais ric rac pour
elisabeth bornes elle emporte avec 52 46
% des voix les donc élu député pour la
toute première fois à l'assemblée
nationale ça c'est pour la situation
personnelle d'elisabeth bande mais très
vite hier après avoir voté la première
ministre est rentré à paris direction
matignon puis l'elysée pour analyser les
résultats du deuxième tour à l'échelle
nationale elle a pris la parole dans la
soirée à écouter en tant que force
centrale dans cette nouvelle assemblée
nous devons assumer une responsabilité
particulière
nous travaillerons dès demain à
construire une majorité d'actions
il n'y a pas d'alternative à ce
rassemblement pour garantir à notre pays
la stabilité et conduire les réformes
nécessaires
donc cette question on a eu la réponse
de jordan bardella juste avant que vous
n'intervenez il avait deux bandes
peut-elle rester à son poste non plus en
tout cas pas si l'on en croit la nu
manuel bompard a lui aussi appelé
aujourd'hui à la démission de la
première ministre écoutez le ce qui est
certain ce qui est évident c'est que
madame ben doit partir
elle est là
directement impactés par le fait qu'elle
n'a pas réussi à constituer une majorité
à l'assemblée nationale donc elle peut
pas rester en place comme ça comme si de
rien n'était et puis on passe à autre
chose et puis on fait des petites des
petites magouilles des petites
discussions comme çà çà çà çà serait pas
à la hauteur du sinel qui a été envoyé
hier soir alors évidemment du côté de la
macro n'y en ait pas du tout du tout
d'accord pour le moment elisabeth board
n'est pas menacée alors oui il y aura un
remaniement ne serait ce que pour
remplacer les trois ministres qui ont
été battu au deuxième tour la question
thomas c'est de savoir si emmanuel
macron voudra ou pas procédé est bien un
remaniement de plus grande envergure en
attendant cet éventuel remaniement
d'envergure
il avait deux bandes va devoir et très
rapidement composer à l'assemblée
nationale lui une grande étape à venir
pour les abeilles bornes au parlement ce
sera le 5 5 juillet le 5 juillet elle
prononcera son discours de politique
générale aucune obligation pour l
d'engager la responsabilité de ce
gouverneur son gouvernement à ce moment
là mais elle devrait fasse faire face à
une motion de censure c'est à dire bien
que des députés de l'opposition vont
procéder à un vote pour montrer leur
désaccord avec la politique du
gouvernement et aussi pourquoi pas pour
tenter de renverser ce gouvernement
attention pour que ça marche il faut que
cette motion réunissent une majorité des
voix c'est à dire 2 189 députés en
l'état actuel des choses ça semble très
compliqué et puis dans les étapes
suivantes sera pense pas forcément se
simplifier c'est ça non à partir du 11
juillet le parlement recommencerait à
fonctionner normalement c'est le début
de ce qu'on appelle la session
extraordinaire
et si elle veut faire voter des textes
adoptés derrière forme elisabeth bande
devra elle aussi revenir 2 189 voix pour
obtenir une majorité or aujourd'hui on
l'a bien vu le camp macro nist compte
245 députés sur 577 il lui manque donc
44 voix qui seront ses 44 députés où
sont-ils que veulent t'ils en échange de
leur soutien il faudra regarder public
sénat pour le savoir un manque évident
on a un très très bon quand c'est il
faut terminer merci steve notamment pour
ce très bon conseil on comparer tout à
l'heure
2022 et
1988 jean daniel lévy la différence
c'est qu'eux ils avaient de bandrélé
plutôt présenté comme techno voulzy
michel rocard un négociateur un homme du
compromis et puis surtout un fin
politique donc ça peut lui manquait à
elisabeth bornes c'est la dimension ça
peut lui manquer en fait on a d'ailleurs
remarqué que dans l'entre-deux tours des
législatives
elle n'a fait aucun déplacement en
dehors de paris hormis dans sa propre
circonscription donc en fait normalement
le rôle qui est dévolu au chef de la
majorité c'est d'aller soutenir les
députés qui sont en difficulté et on a
même vu en fait des candidats aux
législatives qui pensait il avait de
fortes chances de pourra gagner d'aller
soutenir leurs collègues ministres on
peut penser par exemple à monsieur attal
alors même qu' elle n'a pas fait ce type
de déplacement ou qu'on l'a pas vu de
manière extrêmement manifeste comme
étant celle qui allait impulser la
dynamique de campagne
contacter les élus voir les relais être
présente dans la presse et c'est même
quasiment en fait que emmanuel macron
qu'on a entendues avant qu'il ne parte
en roumanie longue c'est effectivement
c'est cette première difficulté puis la
deuxième difficulté c'est que
contrairement à michel rocard si on fait
cette comparaison elle arrive avec une
histoire politique qui est bien plus
vierge que michel rocard lorsqu'il était
là en 1988 c'est à dire sur son passé
politique n'est pas très clairement
identifiés quand on teste sa popularité
c'est extrêmement troublant c'est
qu'elle a exactement la même popularité
que jean castex c'est qu'en fait un peu
de choses près dans la l'image
rétiniennes aux yeux des électeurs qu'on
a interrogés c'est qu'il dise voilà ce
que je pense du précédent premier
ministre j'ai un nouveau prêt ministre
et je vais porter exactement le même
type de regard avant et après l'élection
sanquer d'état de grâce à des passes et
psion qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
différents types et le troisième aspect
elle a souvent été présenté comme étant
quelqu'un qui venait de la gauche comme
étant une personnalité qui avait un
positionnement politique était ancré et
derrière l'écologiste arabe quand vous
regardez la structure de confiance
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas du tout de
soutien de confiance qui vient d'à
gauche c'est vraiment l'électorat
classique d'emmanuel macron donc avec
une surperformance parmi ceux qui se
situe proche de la majorité
présidentielle est également un très bon
score parmi ceux qui sont plutôt à
droite sur l'échiquier politique sans
qu'elle ait attiré une forme de bénéfice
électoral ne serait ce que de 2,7 par
deux franges électorale
béatrice giblin moi j'ai du mal à
imaginer emmanuel macron se séparer
d'elisabeth bornes même si on peut y
voit là on est en train d'évoquer des
raisons d'être objective mais aussi vite
ça me semble un peu c'est le poly de
façon très complète de ce qu'on a
l'habitude de le voir agir il n'aime pas
agir sous la pression il n'aime pas être
contrainte de répondre à une situation
même si la situation est grave et où on
s'attendrait à ce que ils prennent la
parole parce qu'honnêtement le discours
hier soir des
d'elisabeth borne était un discours qui
ne donnaient pas l'impression qu'on
avait pris la mesure du séisme auxquels
ils étaient confrontés
fr une majorité d'actions bon c'était
quand même un peu appelé enfin un peu
léger mais je vois pas tout de suite
mais on peut se tromper emmanuel macron
comme salalah la renvoyer c'est sûr
qu'il ya nécessairement un remaniement
de toute façon parce qu'il ya trois
ministres qu'ils ont battus donc de
toute façon faut refaire un remaniement
c'est un remaniement si on attire des
gens de l air
dire qu'il ya des gens qui sont déjà
passés chez makro mais je pensais à
quelqu'un comme eric woerth par exemple
qui peut de nouveau rentrer dans la
danse et j'ai été battu
52 ans
subissent donc c'est possible il peut
avoir récupéré des gens de cet ordre je
ne la vois pas tenir longtemps dans
disons dans l'aide dur n ont pas ils à
sable sans doute pas larroyer parce que
il ya une forme d'humiliation enfin et
ça je le vois pas faire ça mais
la première grande difficulté d'un texte
important qu'on n'arrivera pas à faire
passer je suis pas sûr qu'elle tienne
vraiment longtemps bon
ses qualités il faut pas aller trop vite
on discute du de la déclaration de
politique générale du sang que julie
ferrez non mais il semblerait que
l'alliance qu'elle veuille en faire
alors aller peut faire une déclaration
de politique générale sans forcément
engagé là réservé ne mentez d'ailleurs
ces deux cas soit ut4h également parce
que la majorité ne dispose plus que
d'une majorité relative et michel rocard
on dit pierre bérégovoy n'ya décret sont
donc ce sera assez facile de le
justifier
le regard de du microcosme et de
l'opinion par rapport aux qualités
d'orateur d'elisabeth borne peut être
assez assez dur si on prend l'exemple de
michel rocard il avait dit je rêve d'un
pays où on se parle à nouveau au filet
fait quelque chose qui avait un peu
marqué les esprits mais encore parce
qu'on connaissait le débit de l'eau
regarde mais enfin ça avait marqué les
esprits c'est un vrai politique là pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore vu une
capacité justement de d'emballement de
dynamique
projetée par elisabeth board c'est pas
pour ça qu'elle a été nommée elle a été
nommée justement pour faire le travail
d'un président jupitérien mais comme le
président jupitérien aujourd'hui est
confrontée à un cas de figure inédit où
il descend de l'olympe
elle est plus tout à fait dans le alors
c'est une vraie question ça m'a tuer ce
que les raisons pour lesquelles emmanuel
macron à nommer elizabeth borne à
matignon
se sont effondrés presse comme un comme
un château de cartes ah oui plus rien ne
tient il fallait une femme de dossiers
bonne technicienne pour faire avancer
des réformes difficiles quelqu'un de
tenace quelqu'un d'opiniâtres est
quelqu'un qui puisse appliquer une
feuille de route ce jeudi ça sans aucune
notion péjorative parce que c'est
parfois difficile d'appliquer une
feuille de route et de s'y tenir elle
avait ses qualités là aujourd'hui on le
voit avec cette majorité toute relative
les grandes réformes les grands
chantiers mais risque d'être réduit à
portion congrue et on a besoin de
quelqu'un qui soit plus politique que
technicien pour justement essayer de
tisser des liens entre des députés hors
de la majorité pour voter des textes
particuliers après c'était une femme dit
de gauche ça sert plus à rien j'ai une
gauche à l'assemblée nationale rôle
qu à autre que par autre que la macro ni
et qu'ils sont plutôt bien représentée
et en fer 131 députés donc de macron
peut toujours dire et je suis de gauche
et de droite qui ne l'a jamais dit
d'ailleurs il n'était pas sur cette
rhétorique là mais elle peut toujours
dit je viens de la gauche les jours de
vie et maintenant on va gauche chez nous
donc ça ne sert plus à rien et elle
était enfin censé incarner
une case plus environnementale parce que
c'est un ministère où il n'avait pas
forcément brillé mais qu'elle avait
occupés et puis avait été directrice de
cabinet de ségolène royal quand elle
était à l'écologie donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a quand même en tout cas là une
bonne connaissance de ces dossiers là et
bien là aussi c'est compliqué elle à sa
mise la transition écologique qui vient
de tomber au tapis dans la législative
bref elle n'est plus la personne qui
cochent toutes les cases tout simplement
parce que les quinze ont changé les
quinze ont changé c'est ce que le dire
après si je me trouve pas je crois
qu'ils manuel macron a eu du mal à
pouvoir trouver et en fait si on écoute
ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron même avant
le fait qu'il soit nouveau élu président
la réplique il avait fixé un cahier des
charges qui est assez précis en fait
c'est ce que devait être la première
mise déjà une femme ensuite avec la
capacité à pouvoir mener la transition
écologique et environnementale et puis
une capacité à pouvoir tenir la majorité
et de la compétence donc en fait c'était
les quatre critères on a entendu si on
prend la presse que d'autres choix
s'était d'abord tournés vers voilà qu'à
l'été et au final c'est
c'est senna me burnand fait et qui est
premier ministre le message politique
d'une femme c'est quasiment le seul
message politique qui a été entendu et
est donc si jamais en fait pour une
raison ou pour une autre il devait se
séparer des bornes je pense qu'il serait
très difficile de ne pas nommer une
femme à matignon hélas dans ce contexte
là
le choix en tout cas si on regarde
l'expérience passée apparaît comme étant
relativement restreint si on se met à la
place d'emmanuel mâcon donc ça ça ajoute
une difficulté en plus un édifice qui
déjà est fragile et le message politique
d'une femme il a été entendu pendant
trois jours les et flinguer par la
sphère abad au goût de tous aujourd'hui
mais ça donc c'est mais si jamais elle
devait partir ce serait le message
il n'y a pas eu d'effet de souffle du
fait que seront que ce soit une ferme à
matignon parce que bien malgré elle
d'ailleurs parce que c'est pas forcément
son sentiment premier elle a dû
conserver damien abad dans son vernis
alors on disait que elle n'allait
certainement pas
engager la responsabilité de son
gouvernement le 5 juillet prochain en
revanche elle doit affronter une motion
de de censure c'est ce qui a été annoncé
par
elle fuit la france insoumise et
notamment par adrien catelet réélu
député du nord on écoute ce qu'il y a 2
clair en tout cas c'est qu'au vu des
résultats d'hier elisabeth bornes doit
s'en aller je crois qu'elle ne peut pas
rester premier ministre pour quoi en
l'état alors après dépôt d'une motion de
censure écouter parce que le dispositif
gouvernemental qui était encore en
présence hier a pris une déroute
monumental voilà donc il faut en tirer
des enseignements politiques alors ce
qui est intéressant et là ça me permet
de d'ouvrir une nouvelle session dans
dans ce débat c'est ce que ça provoque
au sein de la nuque cette proposition
parce que alors de très très vite on a
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste qui déclare ce n'est pas une
position commune à ce stade le fait de
déposer devoir voter une motion de
censure olivier faure qui était sur
france info et là on va le site et je
souhaite que toutes les décisions que
nous prenons au nom de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale se
prennent en commun et non pas du seul
fait des uns ou des autres il va pas
être déçu
bienvenue dans le monde de jean luc
mélenchon c'est quand même un paradoxe
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas
été élu dont etc etc etc a acté le fait
qu' il changer de position il nous l'a
dit je serais plus soit toujours aux
combattants mais plus au même poste dans
qu'il dit n'est plus il n'est plus
député mais c'est lui qui dirige tout
c'est à dire qu'il nous dit d'abord il
faut qu'ils aient un groupe unique nuque
ce qui est totalement contraire y
compris même à la connectique qui a été
passé aux sensibilités politiques qui
existent et qui sont très différents qui
ont eux mêmes actes et leurs divergences
dans le contrat nul oui c est d'ailleurs
à peine on l'a déjà évoqué dans le
premier degré mais à peine jean luc
mélenchon proposer ce groupe unique que
ses alliés disait non c'est d'ailleurs
on l'avait tous d'ici sur ce plateau
depuis longtemps que ça allait très
rapidement
exploser les finement que ça c'était
et puis et puis cette histoire de motion
de censure qui est comme une évidence et
moi moi je jeanteur joue au thème de
contestation de la majorité non il ya
une majorité elle est relative à une
majorité nous disait macro n'a pas de
majorité de 6 il a une majorité mais
elle est relatif donc la justification
de la motion de censure a priori une
motion de censure c'est quand même un
texte alternatif pour proposer quelque
chose face à l'as programme
gouvernemental qui n'existe pas ou en
tout cas qu'on a vu à peine à peine se
dessiner donc ces graisses et on voit
bien là tout artifice delà de la méthode
et on voit bien déjà que la nuque va pas
engager ses forces et aussi pessimiste
pour l'avenir de la nuque batterie
je pense que c'est un accord électoral
enfin je ne comprends même pas comment
mélenchon qui a obtenu l'accord en dix
ans et chacun vous aurez votre groupe
bien sûr et ça a été la condition
nécessaire absolument indispensable pour
qu'ils puissent faire l'alliance or le
lendemain matin il et il leur propose un
groupe unique ça veut dire quoi un
groupe unique ça veut dire qu on
contrôle tout le large ans et que on va
vous leur distribuer vous pensez donc
les autres ils vont jamais avalé une
pilule pareil donc ça les met dans
l'inquiétude aux aguets ah bah si ça
commence comme ça on a intérêt à être
bien d'être inspiré peut être un petit
port
on est tout à fait d'accord surtout pour
un résultat pour le ps d'un nombre de
nuls ps est lui qui est même un peu
inférieur je crois de deux ou trois je
ne me trompe pas donc vraiment c'est si
en plus ils ont pas les sous pour
pouvoir fonctionner enfin c'est oui je
pense qu'on va avoir par exemple au
moment du pouvoir d'achat puisque on dit
que très tôt ses démesures du pouvoir
d'achat qui vont être prises ça va poser
un problème si tout le monde votre nom
citant le rn en disant c'est pas ce
qu'on voulait citant la nubie on vote
non parce que c'est parce qu'on voulait
et pour des gens par exemple le point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires la retraite
indexées sur l'inflation sa retraite
d'eau temps des mesures attendu par
beaucoup dévié sur alors ils vont passer
pourquoi c'est là cela ça va pas être si
ça parce que vous savez les opinions
publiques c'est aussi un peu versatile a
donc dans un cas on a donné une leçon à
maquereau mais dans un autre cas si vous
faites pas ce qu'on veut non plus là ça
va pas aller aller il nous reste sept
huit minutes pour clore ce débat et
cette émission on va parler évidemment
du succès du rassemblement national
mathieu frappé par vous avez été comme
nous tous frappés par ce geste inattendu
oui parce que le résultat a été un peu
occultés par la déroute de la majorité
présidentielle qui conservait de
majorité il faut le dire jean a raison
mais relative et pourtant à mes yeux on
est quand même en train de vivre une
sorte de 21 avril parlementaire alors
l'analogie est forte j'en conviens mais
voir l'extrême droite française devenir
le premier parti d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale c'est un séisme
politique qui vaut bien celui de son
accession au second tour de la
présidentielle en 2002 d'abord parce que
ça a surpris tout le monde vous le
disiez à commencer par les membres du
rassemblement national le même qui
espérait au mieux une cinquantaine de
députés dans un scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours qui ne leur avait jamais été
favorable jusqu'à présent ensuite parce
qu'on en a parlé c'est traduit une
implantation locale qui dépasse
désormais leur traditionnel terre
d'élection le fn progresse en voix
scrutin après scrutin et s'est trouvé de
nouveau bastion déserté par la gauche ou
est inaccessible de la macro ni comme la
ruralité où la france périphérique et
enfin parce que son accession
l'assemblée nationale ça parachève un
travail de dédiabolisation entamé il ya
plus de dix ans par marine le pen le
rassemblement national est devenu un
parti comme les autres qui fait même
plutôt mieux que les autres en vingt ans
il s'est quand même qualifié trois fois
sur cinq pour le second tour des
présidentielles il est arrivé en tête
deux fois sur quatre aux élections
européennes il s'échange désormais dans
bon nombre de collectivités et gère des
municipalités même s'il lui manque
encore des grands exécutifs locaux et il
a finit donc par vaincre le signe indien
des législatives en envoyant 89 députés
seraient même dix fois plus en 2010 est
au palais bourbon oui et je le dis en
titre on parlera sans doute durablement
de ce séisme du 19 juin avec quelles
conséquences politiques mais d'abord
l'entrée massive de députés de
l'assemblée offrir au parti de marine le
pen une forme de respectabilité de
notabilisation en occupant des postes
honorifiques on a parlé de
vice-présidence présidence de la
commission des finances éventuellement
des questure en jouant le jeu d'une
opposition ferme responsable
respectueuse des institutions et
constructive sur les quatre mots
employés par marino peinière soit il va
devenir très difficile voire impossible
pour ses adversaires de soutenir dans
cinq ans que le parti rassemblement
national ne fait pas partie du champ
républicain
rassemblant national veut aussi gagner
des moyens dont on a parlé un petit peu
tout à l'heure puisque le financement la
vie politique est assise en france sur
les résultats législatif principalement
c'est entre 9 et 10 millions d'euros
c'est quasiment le double de la dernière
fois on rappelle que le parti est
endetté à hauteur de 24 millions d'euros
là on parle de 9 à 10 millions d'euros
par an donc ça va quand même effacer la
dette assez vite et puis il ya surtout
il gagnait une tribune un poids
politique pour diffuser ses idées mettre
en difficulté le gouvernement y atteler
questions d'ordre du jour est celle ci
siégera la conférence des présidents
tout pour reprendre la chronique de ce
type tout à l'heure et puis rappelons
aussi qu'il sera en mesure de déposer
une motion de censure il faut être 58
députés pour ça et de saisir directement
le conseil constitutionnel donc séisme
avec des répliques pour les autres
partis
à droite tout d'abord ça donne le
tournis c'est désormais le parti de
marine le pen qui va faire travailler la
poutre selon l'expression consacrée
d'edouard philippe et puis le maquereau
mais on voit bien que ça va bouger un
peu pour tous ceux qui rêvent d'une
union des droites dans la macro ni
ensuite on l'a vu aussi ça donne le
tournis on a quand même vu dès hier soir
nice comme eric dupond moretti qui
s'érigeait et encore trois mois comme un
croquemitaine des lepénistes et qui
tente d'amadouer des élus du
rassemblement national en disant est ce
que vous feriez une des mesures sur une
de mes doigts pour la justice c'est
quand même un signe et puis enfin même
la gauche n'a pas été épargné par ce
séisme puisqu'on volant la place de
premier opposant au nez à la barbe des
insoumis et leur assemblée nationale a
fait se lézarder d'une certaine façon en
une journée la belle façade de delà du
ps donc c'est quand même un sacré c'est
jean daniel lévy jouer qu'on parle quand
même de des résultats du rassemblement
national sur ce plateau choc c'était
mercredi vous étiez là mercredi soir et
je vous avais parlé des projections en
sièges le premier mot vous avez employé
c'était le mot prudent j'ai bien fait et
vous avez
bien fait et bien fait c'est un exercice
difficile qui passa pour le disculper ou
quoi que ce soit à mon cette fois là
c'est un exercice qui est extrêmement
difficile où on a en fait eu des
rapports de force au niveau national
mais il faut qu'on arrive à les projeter
dans 577 circonscriptions avec des
offres électorales qui sont différentes
avec des personnalités qui parfois sont
là et puis avec des incidences du fait
d'avoir en gros un point de différence
en termes d'intentions de vote ça peut
emmener 35 sièges de plus pour une
formation politique et parfois même de
manière mécanique 35 sièges deux mois
pour l'autre formation politique donc ça
veut dire un écart de 70 donc que ça
marche pas exactement comme ça
d'ailleurs aussi nettement tout cas
c'est juste pour qu'on puisse avoir en
fait l'ampleur de la difficulté d'autant
plus qu'on était dans des phénomènes ont
commencé à avoir effectivement des
électeurs qui étaient proches par
exemple de jean luc mélenchon qui
avaient voté ni ps au premier tour et
qui me disait tiens pourquoi je n'irai
pas voter est reine dans le cas d'une
confrontation entre la nuque baisse
entre les rênes pardon et en sort
d'ailleurs on allait
résultat vous l'avez publié pour rtl et
m6 voit le report de voix en cas de duel
ensemble rassemblement national on a 49
% des électeurs et l'eire qui votent
ensemble et 32% pour le rassemblement
national et on a quand on regarde les
électeurs de la nuque cette fois-ci 31 %
pour le candidat de la majorité
présidentielle relative ensemble et 24 %
pour le candidat rassemblement national
et on va voir un autre cas de duel le
duel entre la nuque et le rassemblement
national est là donc on sonde les
électeurs ensemble 34% qui votre nuque
18% qui votre assemblée nationale et
sheller 36% qui vote nul et 27%
rassemblement national derrière le ce on
l'a déjà dit si c'est le front
républicain
atrophiée ou mort
oui très très très profondément
fragilisé parce qu'en face on va on a eu
tout un tas de signaux avant coureurs à
bastings voilà souvent fait le front
républicain ou la défaite du front en
appliquant le voyais par une abstention
massive ou par une montée des blancs et
nuls là c'est un comportement électoral
avec qui se produit alors ce qui était
déjà on avait déjà eu en fait un premier
signe au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle dans les outre-mer ou en
fait il y avait eu une bascule complète
de l'électorat mélenchon premier tour
vers les lecteurs marine le pen au
deuxième tour alors on s'est dit bon
c'est une singularité local c'est lié à
des enjeux précis sur les vaccins et
cetera là on a un quart des électeurs
qui ont voté nul au premier tour et qui
déclare dans une confrontation entre le
ratio national et la formation politique
du président un clic nous allons voter
rassemblement national batterie gym là
on va terminer avec vous il nous reste
un peu moins d'une minute il y en a un
autre atout dans la danse dans le jeu de
marine le pen c'est la cohérence
finalement elle n'est pas au sein d'une
coalition d'une alliance elle peut
tailler la route puis s'est trompée elle
elle est présentée à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui n'est pas le cas de
mélenchon qui s'est quand même privé
d'une tribune jean garrigues l'évoquer
sans qu'on comprenne vraiment bien
pourquoi c'est elle qui physiquement
et va pouvoir tenir véritablement le
rôle d'opposant en ayant le plus gros
groupe à elle seule alors après il va
savoir bien l'utiliser bon elle a quand
même pris le métier donc à mon sens elle
va savoir faire on termine là dessus
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé
à cette émission et à ce débat jean
garrigues rappel le titre de votre livre
la tentation du sauveur on est aux
éditions payot jeu